WILL
>> Pete: AMERICANS ARE BEGINNING
TO FIGHT BACK VACCINE ENFORCERS
KNOCKING ON THEIR DOORS AND
TRYING TO COLLECT THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
>> WHO ARE YOU?
WHO ARE YOU?
HOW DID YOU GET IN THIS
BUILDING?
>> VACCINE.
>> HOW DID YOU GET IN THIS
BUILDING?
WHO ARE YOU?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE.
>> WE HAVE A [INAUDIBLE]
>> YOU DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO BE
IN THIS BUILDING ASKING PEOPLE.
IT'S A VIOLATION OF PEOPLE'S
HIPAA RIGHTS.
>> OKAY, GET OUT.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO BE
HERE.
YOU GET OUT OF THIS BUILDING
NOW.
>> MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU ARE VIOLATING PEOPLE'S
PRIVACY RIGHTS.
GET OUT.
GET OUT NOW.
>> Pete: GOOD FOR HER AND THEY
MUMBLE AND SHUFFLE AWAY.
THE WHITE HOUSE CALLS PEOPLE
LIKE THESE, THESE FOLKS IN THE
YELLOW VEST THAT HAPPEN TO BE IN
LOS ANGELES A VERY NECESSARY
TOOL IN THEIR ARSENAL TO FIGHT
POLITIC SIDING THE VACCINE.
AND STOPPING BIG GOVERNMENTS,
YOU GUESSED IT, NEWEST ENEMY,
MISINFORMATION.
>> WE HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL
AND WE ARE MINDFUL OF BEING
QUITE CAREFUL OF NOT
POLITICIZING THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF VACCINES.
WE HAVE EMPOWERED, ENGAGED
FUNDED LOCAL VOICES BECAUSE THEY
ARE OFTEN THE MOST TRUSTED
VOICES.
DOCTORS, MEDICAL EXPERTS,
CLERGY, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WHO ARE
MEMBERS OF CIVIC LEADERS IN
COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE PUTTING MOST
OF OUR RESOURCES.
>> Pete: OKAY.
THEY ARE NOT POLITICIZING IT.
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOT WHITE
HOUSE IS FUNDING OR EMPOWERING.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT SOME OF THE
QUOTE TRUSTED MESSENGERS
KNOCKING ON AMERICANS' DOORS
THEY ARE NOT DOCTOR, PASTORS AND
LEADERS.
FAUCI AND FRIENDS ARE MAKING
THEM OUT TO BE.
IN FACT, THIS WEEK WE SHOWED YOU
HOW THE TRUSTED MESSENGERS IN
NORTH CAROLINA WHO ARE GATHERING
INFORMATION AND GIVING OUT SHOTS
AT YOUR DOOR WERE LARGELY
DEMOCRAT POLITICAL OPERATIVES
BELONGING TO GROUPS LIKE ACTION
NC.
AND WE SHOWED A BUNCH OF OTHER
GROUPS IN OTHER STATES INVOLVED
IN SIMILAR EFFORTS ALL LEFT WING
GROUPS.
WHICH CALLS INTO QUESTION WHAT
EXACTLY ARE THEY DOING WITH ALL
THE DATA THEY ARE COLLECTING?
AND AS IT TURNS OUT, THIS IS
MUCH MORE WIDESPREAD THAN WE
INITIALLY THOUGHT.
IT'S NOT JUST HAPPENING AS WE
SAID IN NORTH CAROLINA.
THESE VAXIVIST SEEM TO BE
TARGETING SWING STATES
CONVENIENT.
THEY HAVE BEEN SPOTTED IN STATES
LIKE GEORGIA, FLORIDA,
WISCONSIN, AND MANY OTHERS.
BUT DON'T WORRY, CNN SAYS THIS
IS A NONPARTISAN EFFORT, QUOTE.
THIS GROUP, THIS GROUP IN
GEORGIA, LEARNED THEIR
CANVASSING SKILLS IN THE
POLITICAL ARENA.
THEY VOLUNTEERED FOR YEARS WITH
THE RANDOLPH COUNTY DEMOCRAT
COMMITTEE.
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE GROUP
WANTED TO BUILD ON MOMENTUM FROM
THE 2020 ELECTION AND LAUNCHED
THE PROGRAMS NONPARTISAN VACCINE
EFFORT.
FROM DEMOCRAT CANVASSER TO
NONPARTISAN VACCINE MESSENGER.
WHAT AN INTERESTING CAREER PATH.
LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
WHEN HAS A DEMOCRAT OPERATIVE
EVER DONE SOMETHING OUT OF THE
KINDNESS OF THEIR HEART AND WHO
IS PAYING FOR THIS?
PROBABLY YOU AND ME.
AND WHY SHOULD WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS A MOVEMENT TO PROTECT
THE COMMUNITY AND NOT A LARGE
SCALE GROUND CAMPAIGN AHEAD OF
MIDTERM AND PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS?
SPEAKING OF LONG-TERM AND LARGE
SCOPE GROUND CAMPAIGNS LET'S
TALK TO KARL ROVE FORMER WHITE
HOUSE DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF AND
A FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
KARL, EACH DAY WE LEARN MORE AND
MORE WHETHER IT'S THE TALKING
POINTS THEY HAVE AT THE DOOR,
WHETHER IT'S THE STATES THAT
THEY ARE IN, WHETHER IT'S THE
CAUSES THEY OTHERWISE FIGHT FOR
AND THEY ALWAYS SEEM TO LINE UP.
STATES THAT MATTER, LEFT WING
GROUPS PUSHING VACCINES.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS DISTURBING.
LOOK, I'M IN FAVOR OF OUTREACH
EFFORTS.
WE HAVE GOT TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
THESE LIFE-SAVING VACCINES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BUT IT OUGHT TO BE DONE ENTIRELY
OUTSIDE OF POLITICS.
DONE BY DOCTORS AND NURSES AND
HEALTH EDUCATIONS AND PEOPLE
DRAWN FROM THE HEALTH EDUCATION
PROGRAMS AT COLLEGES AND THE
SCOUTS AND SERVICE GROUPS AND
CHURCHES AND LOCAL LEADERS.
IT SHOULDN'T BE POLITICS.
THE ACTION NORTH CAROLINA IS AN
INTENSELY LEFT WING VERY
IDEOLOGICAL AND VERY ACTIVE
POLITICAL GROUP.
GO TO THEIR WEBSITE.
IT STARTS WITH A GIGANTIC CALL
ON THE READERS OF THE WEBSITE TO
DEMAND THAT SENATORS TILLIS AND
BURR BOTH REPUBLICANS SUPPORT
THE PRESIDENT AND EXPAND
GOVERNMENT, SPEND MORE MONEY,
AND, IN FACT, IN THEIR
DESCRIPTION OF THEIR MISSION
THEY SAY THEIR MISSION IS TO
GROW POLITICAL POWER AND, YET,
THEY ARE SOMEHOW INVOLVED AND
SHADY ARE WE USING TAXPAYER
DOLLARS?
WE'RE CERTAINLY USING TAXPAYER
DOLLARS BUT, LOOK, WE DO FOR
THIS.
WE ARE USING TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
PAY FOR THE VACCINES AND THE
SUPPORT SERVICES.
SO, ARE WE IN ESSENCE
SUBSIDIZING A POLITICAL
ORGANIZATION IN BETWEEN
ELECTIONS?
YOU MENTIONED RANDOLPH COUNTY,
GEORGIA.
BOBBY JENKINS, THE LONG-TIME
CHAIR HAS A NEIGHBOR TO NEIGHBOR
CANVASSING ORGANIZATION AND
THAT'S WHAT IS OPENLY DOING THE
WORK IN RANDOLPH COUNTY.
IF YOU ARE IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND YOU ARE ATTEMPTING TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM.
DO YOU REALLY WANT TO POLLUTE IT
WITH A BIG DRAWUP OF HIGHLY
PARTISAN AND IDEOLOGICAL GROUPS
RATHER THAN FOCUSING IN ON THE
MISSION AT HAND.
ARE THESE PEOPLE AROUND IN LET'S
SAY, NEBRASKA?
ARE THESE PEOPLE IN LET'S SAY,
RHODE ISLAND?
ARE THESE PEOPLE AROUND IN NEW
MEXICO?
ARE THESE PEOPLE AROUND IN, SAY,
OREGON?
NO, NO, YOU ARE RIGHT.
IT APPEARS LIKE THEY ARE MAINLY
ACTIVE.
IN FACT, THE LIST I HAVE SEEN IS
VIRTUALLY ONLY STATES THAT ARE
SWING STATES CLOSE STATES FOR
THE 2020 ELECTION.
SOMEBODY IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
SOMEBODY AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES HAS TO
BE HELD TO ACCOUNT WHO IS MAKING
THESE DECISIONS?
WHO IS ALLOWING POLITICS TO
ENTER INTO SOMETHING THAT OUGHT
TO BE AS FAR AWAY FROM POLITICS
AS POSSIBLE.
>> Pete: THAT'S A GREAT POINT,
KARL.
FEELS LIKE A CONVENIENT TWO FOR.
VACCINE EFFORT AND GATHERING
DATA.
IS THIS USEFUL.
>> OH, GOSH.
THINK ABOUT IT THINK ABOUT IT.
YOU GO TO RANDOLPH COUNTY,
GEORGIA.
AND YOU STICK THE NEEDLE IN THE
ARM AND THEN YOU COME BACK A
YEAR LATER AND SAY NOW JUST,
REMEMBER, WE FROM THE RANDOLPH
COUNTY DEMOCRAT
NEIGHBOR-TO-NEIGHBOR PROGRAM
CAME BY AND TOOK CARE OF YOU.
AND YOU NEED TO RESPOND BY
VOTING DEMOCRAT.
YOUR ACTION NORTH CAROLINA.
WE, THE PROGRESSIVES, BUILDING
POLITICAL POWER, WE ARE BACK ON
YOUR DOORSTEP, REMINDING YOU
THAT WE WERE HERE LAST YEAR WITH
A LIFE-SAVING VACCINE.
>> Pete: INTERESTING.
>> WHO HAS GOT THIS DATA?
WHERE IS THIS DATA BEING SHARED
AND WHY ARE THEY ALLOWING
EXPRESSLY POLITICAL GROUPS TO BE
INVOLVED?
>> Pete: HOW CAN WE GET THAT
ANSWER, KARL HOUGH IS FUNDING IT
OR IS IT TOO OBSCURED THE WAY
BUREAUCRACY PAID GROUPS AND
PRIVATE PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP?
>> SOME OF THESE STATES LIKE
GEORGIA HAVE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS THEY OUGHT TO BE
DEMANDING ANSWERS.
MY GUT TELLS ME THEY HAVE
REACHED OUT TO STATE DEPARTMENTS
TO HELP BE INVOLVED IN THESE
PROGRAMS.
WE NEED TO HAVE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS IN ALL OF THESE
BATTLEGROUND STATES THAT ARE
HAVING THESE KIND OF PROGRAMS
RAISE QUESTIONS AND DEMAND
ANSWERS FROM THE SECRETARY OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHO IS IN CHARGE OF THIS PROGRAM
AND WE ALSO OUGHT TO CHALLENGE
THE MEDIA, ALL OF THE MEDIA TO
GO OUT THERE.
IMAGINE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
THIS WERE A YEAR AGO AND DONALD
TRUMP WAS USING THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY ORGANIZATION OR THE
AMERICAN CONSERVATIVE UNION OR
EMPOWER AMERICA OR THE KOCH
BROTHERS AMERICANS FOR
PROSPERITY TO DELIVER SHOTS AND
DOING SO OPENLY?
LOOK, IT'S ONE THING IF A BUNCH
OF VOLUNTEERS WHO HAVE A
POLITICAL BACKGROUND SHOW UP AND
SAY WE ARE GOING TO JOIN THE
TRAVIS COUNTY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT OF THIS
EFFORT.
IT'S ANOTHER THING WHEN IT IS
OPENLY AND ACTIVELY POLITICAL
GROUPS.
IT.
>> Pete: SO TRUE COULD YOU
IMAGINE CHARLIE KIRK AND CANDACE
OWENS SHOWED UP WITH A BAGS OF
NEEDLES?
THE DOUBLE STANDARD.
>> IT'S JAW DROPPING.
>> Pete: KARL, YOU ARE RIGHT.
THEY SHOULD BE ASKED AT THE
PRESS PODIUM TOMORROW AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE WHERE THIS IS COMING